a company outing oklahoma is producing
for one thousand dollars bulletproof
blankets for kid use in schools because
the
thing about a school shooting the course
we had another one yesterday just never
stop there was a one week before
we've got some images a blanket 3i
thousand bucks he can protect against
ninety percent of the weapons that have
been used
in school shootings in the United States
there were 13 school shootings in the US
the first six weeks
up 2014 we're now for months past that
and so I guess purse is this just
inevitable
that every kid is gonna be going to
school with the a bullet-proof blanket
I don't even have words for how
appalling the idea that we now have two
kevlar
our kids blankets in the schools because
god forbid we do
any tiny tiny thing about guns in this
country
in said no we all have to be walk around
with bulletproof vests
that's the answer I i KK my me I
definitely think they're
a good idea you know i mean the there'd
attempting to solve
there's something to put out the smoke
rather than put out the fire
ran for like a better X expression by
Tom because it doesn't look like gun
reform is happening anytime soon in this
country and people are actually dying in
a manner as just another shooting
that occurred you know yesterday arm
I think that to have those in school to
be a a positive thing and the animal
approve doors
but they've been experiment where is it
all a little bit absurd a fake
protection because
the idea that the kid would be you know
with when this would happen I assume
they don't keep them on them all the
time or probably even under their desks
that
you know you mean by the time you were
able to get it out of the closet or
something
the bathtub is already have so I do this
is just sorta just I do with it is it
bakery for the pairing emma is it that
telling kids oh by the way you could get
shot at any moment
so do keep this handy enos so that's the
part that I think the most intriguing do
you think that would be that
the real bad part is the conditioning
that all these kids are gonna grow up
thinking that this is just
really part of the way like this even
though I I guess is at some level but
also I i think that you have to adapt to
the times like I went to highschool
are elementary school in manhattan and
we are remember growing up we had drills
where we have to get into the deaths in
case there was a
like a nuclear attack or something like
that up in the fifties
no there isn't doing enough for you
otherwise I remember there was
you have to get on the desks and brace
yourself for some kind of like
attack or something like that yeah to as
like in New York and obviously I don't
think that that a
applies today but today we have this
very real and present
you know dangerous school shootings
something i read online this week that
was interesting was that one of the
great semantic
to remove you know twists over
everything years is that we keep calling
these shootings
and nobody ever calls them murders then
if we called the murders maybe we were
taken more seriously but
shootings different things more
innocuous than that and that allowed at
the kinda
process this on a daily basis that is
constantly happening
and we are more appalled by the yeah is
that the other scary part here is that
so when I saw the shooting yesterday
I remember where was where was it
because this happens constantly who are
already know the right was an organ and
I guess the shooter and one other
the guy in North Hollywood couple days
ago right and then what what was one
last week the
last week was getting santa Barbara is
that we can have a
um but i think is happening in this go
to the conditioning part
is what I see on Twitter there's a
shooting now it doesn't even phase me
for a split second or you know to me to
my co
another one make and that to me is the
scary parts are we just becoming
the warrior yeah I mean are we just
becoming more and more
okay with it so I so this is something
these blankets even if its
not real protection I saw your flakes
are completely exposed on those things
you know yeah I mean the guy was the day
you get what you needed 200 medley
something like a big turtle show
you should get that is I wouldn't do
anything to do with I
really get a boner I mean if they save
one life you know I answer
that there is a great initiative yeah um
so that we can change gun laws which it
seems like
we can't seem to do since we couldn't
get anything passed after a new town and
area
the if we can't do that then what what
should we beat actually tacking meant to
help more
because it seems to me that so I guess
is a lot to do with mental health and
prescription drugs only one shot ahead
said yesterday though with their withers
mentally hell
mentally ill people all over the world
and there are violent video games
all over the world and there are
frustrated single guys all over the
world
this is the country where all those
people get gotten better
yeah exactly to yes any video game
caused by later they say every time I be
an Italian plumber eating my cum jumping
a turtle
I am the measure that is they really do
with about the video game